the following is a conversation with
mark normand a new york comedian who has
a way with words that is often both dark
and hilarious
let that be a warning dear friends to
proceed with caution and to wear
protection
you may in fact need it he has a special
on his youtube called out to lunch and a
new special on netflix as part of the
stand up season 3 series i recommend you
watch
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with mark
normand
i asked him dylan about bukowski first
so let me continue on that tradition and
ask you about something that charles
bukowski said about love wait are we
rolling
yes oh geez no hello no nothing nope i
thought i was robotic
buckowski said love is a fog that burns
away with the first daylight of reality
so uh mark norman let me first ask you
about love uh
what are your thoughts about love you
talk about your relationships quite a
bit
do you think love can last
i do
but i think it's work everybody wants
love to be this
pre-packaged perfect euphoric thing but
it you gotta
it's like a good body you know we're all
born with a good body but you gotta keep
it in shape and it's the same with a
loving relationship
i think you uh nobody wants to do the
work that's the problem
you talked about i think you told a
story about being unfaithful to a
previous girlfriend or something like
that
i think the story goes that
you were like drifting apart who are you
talking to bert crusher maybe or
something like that yeah
high school sweethearts dated for like
12 years and then
so that wasn't love anymore that was
more like relation that was like it was
comfort it was routine and uh we just
slipped into that kind of married life
autopilot
world and uh
i tried to break up i think and it
didn't take it was one of those things
our lives were just so
baked in
and then i think i uh cheated and she
caught me and it was ugly and then we
went to therapy to try to work it out
but it's it's much like a car that gets
into a wreck the door just never closed
the same
you know what i mean yeah so what are
your thoughts about then um commitment
like outside of love marriage
i think it's an antiquated idea i think
it's kind of silly and unrealistic
and i think we're coming out of that as
we get all polyamorous and non-binary
and queefy and all this stuff i think
we're
slowly moving away from that but uh i
think a lot of the ladies
more majority women like marriage like
the idea of it
like i'm i'm i'm a fiance now or
whatever you call it i'm engaged and i
mean she is just
going hog wild she's loving it she's got
the dress thing pick a venue flow and
she's
she's deep in whereas i feel guilty
because i'm just like
oh
geez
is it planned already where's the
wedding you see squid game i'm just
living life uh yes
it's it's uh planned it's in new orleans
i'm from there and uh it's next year
are you married no single virgin
of course yeah i can't imagine i bet
you'd be great in bed you ripped i had
the best hairline in podcasting
yeah i don't know i haven't tried yet so
we'll have to see all right well let me
know pretty big hog on you
yeah i could see you packing a crazy
crazy tool downtown
that matters to girls apparently yeah
that's all i hear about
okay new orleans you grew up in new
orleans yeah born and raised
treme outside the french quarter you
ever been yeah
don't remember it oh you drink yeah i
drink of course i drink i don't know i
can't tell if you have fun no not really
but russia i mean russian of course i
drink all that kind of stuff
beer was just labeled an alcoholic
beverage in 2011.
fun fact what do you mean in russia
it was just drinks it was just like
apple juice before it finally got
declared legally as an alcoholic
beverage
which means you can regulate it that
kind of thing i guess so yeah see that's
where your brain goes yeah yeah i just
go out of these [ __ ] ruskies i didn't
even know there's rules about drinking
that's good i'm learning about russia
from you so um what's the difficult
memory experience from childhood
in new orleans that uh
made you
the man you are today um i don't know if
it made me the man but uh jeez
i had a lot of uh s
scuffles in the neighborhood with i was
the white kid in the neighborhood so i
was uh automatically
the odd man out the minority the weirdo
the dork the dweeb the honky
so uh just a lot of memories of like
getting slapped in the face by guys and
just having to take it because there's
like five guys there and they'd be like
oh look you don't even fight back and
you're like what am i gonna do hit you
and then get beat up by these guys so a
lot of that stuff was a
big bummer growing up got robbed all the
time
lost a lot of bicycles had a bicycle
taken from under me that was pretty
brutal
uh these kids pulled up you know they're
like 17 and i was
13 and i had a
face paint on like i had a not black
face but i was at a summer camp and i
had a a rainbow face painted on me we
were helping kids that day so i let them
put paint on me
and uh so now i'm riding home what a
mark what uh what a goober i am i'm
riding home and these guys see me a mile
away i'm a sitting duck and they go we
can take his bike he's got a [ __ ]
rainbow on his cheek
so uh they just go hey
you're like cut in front of ya they go
let me try your bike i go i'm good i'm
good i knew what they wanted
and uh they go let me try the bike and
then just push me and took the bike
so stuff like that was really uh shaping
the insecurity the
self-worth
did it uh
because i've been mugged when i was
younger too really
yeah it changes your view of human
nature a little bit for sure you go wow
i didn't know people could be this mean
this yeah
yeah inconsiderate i'm always worried
about it did i fart too much am i
annoying am i pissing this guy off but
what a way to live just
i want the bike i'm taking it [ __ ] his
feelings
for me that quickly turned into um
realizing that that's just a temporary
phase that those folks are in like they
there's a they have a capacity to be
good sure for some reason
for me that was a motivation to see can
we discover can can we incentivize
them to find like a better path in life
like i i wasn't like all like
i don't know gandhi about it you know of
course i was pissed and all those kinds
of things but
i don't know it seemed
like
just the kind of thing
you might do when you're younger yeah
hope what is adult
crime obviously
yeah i know but yeah exactly and then it
solidifies and then you're beyond saving
at some point but it's like there's
always
there's always an opportunity to uh
to make a better uh
life for yourself to to become a better
version of yourself yeah and i remember
coming home crying with no bike and my
mom she's my parents are like
liberal to a fault yeah you know where
they were like oh well they need it
they're poor kids in the neighborhood
you're like all right but i i also like
i have a bicycle that uh i ride around
you know and i also like to live in an
area that's not just
you know riddled with uh theft and
vandalism but
they were like oh they need it and then
it was it was a moot point we just moved
on so i remember very young being like
all right i gotta figure my [ __ ] out
okay
so
you said you were beat up quite a bit
like bullying and stuff pushed around i
was never hospitalized or anything but
you know you get a black guy here and
there and a bloody nose stuff like that
and it was just the outnumbered thing
the violence didn't really
bother me because you're just kids
you're boys yeah but it was the
predatory let's get him you know we can
take him down
he's you know he's an easy target that's
what kills you yeah the mental part
yeah you know until you actually said i
didn't realize i've been in what do you
call them scuffles
and uh there's just one that stands out
to me where yeah let's hear it fatty
bring it on
and you do jujitsu and all that stuff
right yeah you can see the guns through
the suit you're like john wick all right
uh all right well i used to have now
you're gonna start making fun of me i
used to have long hair for for like a
couple years i was in a band playing
music and stuff like that and there was
um like most of the fights i've been in
were basically one-on-one maybe a little
bit like
a little
extra stuff but not outnumbered and this
one particular time
i've learned a lot of lessons but one of
them was i
there's the fight started between me and
this other person and then
uh his buddies i guess were there uh-oh
and they as opposed to like breaking up
or letting it happen
um one of them grabbed my hair
it's the first time anybody grabbed like
use my hair in a fight which i've
since then realized that that's actually
a really powerful grip and a powerful
weapon oh very vulnerable of you and
then my uh head got pulled back and they
pulled me down to the guard like i
couldn't do anything so i remember being
exceptionally frustrated yeah like that
was the feeling like i can't do anything
here i'm like trapped
and then they they were just like
kicking me and hitting me and stuff like
that and the outnumbered part of it
um
because i always kind of remember the
trapped part because i just hated from a
fighting grappling perspective
how like like the feeling was this isn't
fair yes that's what it is it's a deep
deep unfairness yeah that you just can't
you can't win the mob wins yeah the mob
wins scary stuff and but it makes a mix
of man out of it a weird way that builds
character you realize life isn't fair
early and you
you go on from there yeah so there's
something there and look at you today
they're probably uh you know eaten out
of a dumpster at a krispy kreme and
you're here got eight podcasts yeah
you're doing great talking to the giant
titans of the industry no i i do
remember returning home that night
i mean that you said you were crying
that's really formative like oh yeah
that's the point in which you get to
decide what do i make of this moment i
mean especially when you're younger
maybe it's not presented to you that way
but like some of the greatest people in
history
were
bullied in these kinds of ways and they
made something of themselves in this
moment like bully by life in some kind
of way it's like an opportunity for
growth it's um
it's weird but like hardship even in
small doses is like an opportunity for
growth totally i mean look at richard
pryor they say he's labeled as the best
community of all time grew up in a
whorehouse watch his mom get plowed by
these guys in in the middle of
indiana i want to say and uh just who
had a harder life he would suck dick for
drugs all this stuff growing up beat up
and uh
then the weird thing is oops sorry
that's my birth control alarm and then
the uh the whole world is like trying to
get rid of bullying but we still do
bullying but now it's accepted bullying
it's very strange so you're uh your
proponent of uh beating kids up is that
yes and sex with them all right
but no uh
i just think it's part of life and it's
horrible it is it's like rain you gotta
have it look a rainy day is a bummer you
know but you need it and uh i think it's
similar to that
what was your relationship like with
your uh
your mom your dad well what are some
memorable moments with them what did you
learn from them good parents
the giving thoughtful
uh
a little out to lunch you know they were
workaholics so there was it was hard to
get a lot out of them and my dad was
kind of an angry dad i think he just had
like a
weird childhood and he's just trying to
make it he's trying to provide but it's
hard and we live in this horrible
neighborhood and we're getting robbed
all the time
um so life was kind of coming down on
him all the time so then he'll take it
out on you or whoever he would snap
but great parents they cared they put us
first
um but there wasn't a lot of
how do you see you know you ever go to a
friend's house as a kid and there's like
a picture of a ski trip and you're like
ski trip what the hell is that about you
know
it was a lot of that and
smart very smart people but i don't know
how well they were at uh socializing so
you never like bonded with them like on
a deep human level like some bonnie but
it rarely deep yeah it was just you know
almost co-worker hey cold out
huh what it's cold out huh oh yeah like
that kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah i
gotcha get there a little bit but it
my parents and i hope they never saw
this but they would do a thing where my
dad especially would do a thing where he
would uh he knew how to cut you down
right to the bone and so after a while
you're like i'm not gonna interact with
this guy because he he can get you so
well one time we were at a uh like a
thanksgiving some kind of family of
event and all the cousins are there and
i remember i was holding court i was a
young boy
finding my comedic legs in this weird
tumultuous sea we call a family and i
was killing and um my dad comes up and
goes what are you holding court
and i was like ah and i felt like i was
this big i just
shrunk down he just nailed it because in
my head i'm like i'm holding court look
at me i got the whole room and he goes
what are you what are you holding cord
here yeah like who the hell do you think
you are and i was like
he's right i should be holding guard who
the [ __ ] am i i'm nobody so uh
stuff like that was he aware that you
think he wasn't he wasn't i don't think
he was but
do you do you give um parents a pass
when they're unaware
of the destructive like is it better
when they're unaware because it seems
like that's the way that's true that's
why the way parents often fail is
they're not
intentionally malevolent
they're just like clueless yeah
it's a bittersweet thing cause you're
like well okay he's not malicious he's
not trying to hurt me
but also
he doesn't know he hurt me i don't know
it's it's tough because if he was trying
to hurt you
i guess that would be worse
so you're the fully baked
mark norman cake at this point uh what
yeah it's a cheap cake
do you uh fruit salad
you know the sense of self-worth you
mentioned
i think in your comedy there's a sense
like you hate yourself you think
i didn't know if that came through [ __ ]
i was trying to hide that part
god damn it i mean when you like in the
privacy of your own mind
are
you able to love yourself or is it
mostly self-hate oh jeez what happened
to this podcast i didn't know it was on
uh mr or dr phil dr phil i thought we
were going to talk about engineering and
and climate change and
rockets uh we'll get there okay starts
with love goes to rockets all right i
like that i like that's a t-shirt
um
i mean like what's the question sorry
do i feel love no no like i love myself
yeah yeah so are you um
like this engine of being self-critical
of just being constantly anxious
about how the world perceives you these
kinds of things
is this something that you just go to
for for comedy or is this
who you are as a human being
i think i i don't want to explore it i
think i get around it you know i tap
dance around it but i get it out a
little with my act maybe because i i
can't do it i'm not doing it in real
life so i'll
get out this uh no love
not loving myself i don't know who wants
to love himself everybody always said
you got to love yourself and then when
you meet somebody who does love yourself
you're like i [ __ ] hate this guy
don't you hate the guy who's upset i'm
great i'm awesome life is good like ah
this guy sucks
i'd rather an insecure guy so maybe i
want to stay insecure maybe i don't want
to find this love for myself
well okay so self love like just
appreciating
who you are like appreciating the moment
of being grateful doesn't have to
express itself by the guy saying
i'm awesome true it's more just like
humility he's just like walking calmly
to the world and just being grateful to
be alive that kind of thing and just
good and like being appreciative of all
the accomplishments he made so far i say
all this because
mostly i'm extremely self-critical in
everything i do and so
uh and i kind of enjoy it i think it's a
nice little engine that it makes it fun
it makes life fun because it's like
if you hate everything you do
like you've done in the past that gives
you like all right we can do better yes
but that's the key is making itself
critical always trying to get better i
could change this i could tweak this i
can improve this
when you just go i hate that i do this i
suck you just shut down so that's the
key is is always being productive with
the uh with the criticism yeah and the
basics of life i'm just like grateful
for it to be alive that's nice to be a
couple like couple that with uh two legs
again the hairline the hog the muscles
the the the world you got a good brain
on you i mean you're you're lucky you're
in the top
you know most people are fat as [ __ ] at
burger king right now hitting their kids
yeah you're in a ramada hotel
sitting with the
you know a low-level comedian for the
record i ate mcdonald's last night
all right well you're human
well just you know this is not me
defending i'm not sponsored by
mcdonald's but i mostly eat meat and
there's nothing wrong with the the beef
they have
it's actually one of the easiest ways
late at night i think a two two i don't
know if it's actually it's it's actually
rats yeah you're right
but hey it's just meat i'm a meat guy
myself
uh they say in 20 years we're going to
look back and go uh can you believe
people ate meat it's kind of like
somebody like slavery
yeah there's some ethical difficult
things with uh factory farming yeah so
let's ride it out now but we still got
it
and now it's on record
tom waits says something about new york
you like tom weights i think he's
underrated i think he's got great he's
got a great uh he's great at quips and
quotes
check him out on youtube he's got some
montages and super cuts of him being
hilarious what does he say about um
i'd rather have a bottle in front of me
than a frontal lobotomy that was the one
that was the one that sold me i was like
this guy's awesome yeah but his music
because he's just a genius musician yeah
anyway he was talking about new york i
was walking around this i'm in new york
right now we're in new york right now
it's still a magical city to me a lot of
people are quite cynical about it about
the state of things but
well not not like michael males like a
lot of friends of mine they're just a
lot of folks in san francisco and new
york there's something about the
pandemic where people have become
quite cynical about the place they are
and they tried to escape
it's interesting i mean they're asking
some difficult questions about what they
are in life they're having like a
self-imposed midlife crisis is it's good
i think for everybody to go through this
process but i think i hope new york
reemerges
it will as the flourishing place for the
weirdos anyway the tom wade said new
york of course
is to be in endless surreal situations
where a 50 000
gunmetal mercedes pulls up in a puddle
of blood and outsteps a 25 karat blonde
with a two dollar wristwatch
and he goes he keeps going on so like
it's like um
that's like bars he's like a rabbit yeah
he's good uh
but basically just the absurdity of it
all lots of money lots of weirdos
uh degenerates and dreamers and the
whole the whole mix of it do you think
um
i think that's an accurate description
of what new york is today like is there
still place for the weirdos and just the
interesting artists
the the edgy the comedians the the
creators
the the
the entrepreneurs like
as opposed to like wall street as
opposed to like
rich folk
and then like
hopeless folk yeah i think it's
definitely changed a lot there's a
there's a tiny corner for us weirdo
artists new york used to be where you
went to make it as a painter or whatever
a comedian or a singer and there were
all these dives and [ __ ] boxes and all
these places you could go
and now there's now it's more
pinkberries and
subway sandwiches and chase banks so
it's definitely lost a lot of its uh
creative edge it's just money money
keeps coming in and now you see all
these comedians moved to nashville
austin denver whatever so uh
it doesn't have the the power it used to
have of like you gotta be here if you
want to make it that's definitely gone
uh so
that hurt the city a lot the city is is
way more soulless
when i moved here in 07 i mean not only
did i get mugged three times in the
first year
but
it was
a hub of like it felt like things were
happening here you know it was it was an
energy it was electricity and we still
have the electricity but it's also maybe
just because it's time square there's
soho there's uh wall street so we got
the staples but there is a little bit of
that it's almost like a marriage like
yeah we're in love but it's not as
passionate as it once was
that's how i would equate new york
what gives you hope you're pretty
hopeful about it though i'm hopeful just
because i know it's magical and i and i
think
it has to be i mean it's the epicenter
of america like this is where the
immigrants came and this is where
the stock market is and the
entertainment industry a lot of it is
here so
i think it's it's gonna happen but it
all something like the bottom has to
fall out and then people have to move
back here and all that so something
the corporations are kind of [ __ ] us
they're just buying everything well
that's true for everything that's
awesome for everything it's true for
austin probably as well people just
buying out land and all that kind of
stuff you always hear a hemingway and
dali and all these guys went to paris
in the 20s or whatever that was
yeah i get it now i'd be like why do
these guys go to paris you know what are
these
artists and now i get it because it's
like it's freer there that's why austin
became like that paris where everybody's
like i gotta get out of la i'm going
there
and uh
maybe but we came back from that you
know the 70s were wild and 90s were cool
so maybe it'll come back might just take
a decade well there's always that's how
stories are told there's always pockets
of
like
paris within new york right
there's just an opportunity to
let your weird flourish is there in new
york i'm sure they're i mean
um
it's there you gotta find it before it
was front and center
what's your favorite thing about new
york like what what kind of
things just like i mean how long's this
pod i could go on it's just it's too
much to
to put into one hour we've got other
questions but
i love that one neighborhood is wildly
different than the next i'm in little
italy and then you take four steps now
i'm in chinatown i mean and then the
history there and then the stories
and the food and the culture and all
that
and then you go ten feet over here and
now you're in brooklyn and this is
insane there's a whole other world and
it's it's almost like a little america
in one
you know uh city and it's great and uh
just the fact that they pulled it off
like
fifth avenue goes way up and you're like
there's a billionaire's house next to a
hobo and then this is a black guy who's
fighting with a cuban guy and an asian
guy's uh trying to get in the middle of
them and the cabbies from uh the middle
east and
there's so many beautiful women here and
there's so many brilliant minds here and
and the pace is great it keeps people
moving i mean it just
you can't beat it i mean the city will
[ __ ] you in the ass too don't get me
wrong you landed jfk and you're like oh
god i got mugged my uh my uber driver
called me a homo i stepped in and human
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] am i
um so yeah it's it's bad news but that
bad news it's almost like the bullying
it kills you in a weird way but it makes
you stronger and you build more layers
and layers and layers that's why some
new guys some hayseed from milwaukee
shows up you've been here 10 years and
you go let me let me help you out
because uh you're you you gotta adjust
you're gonna get your ass kicked for
like six months but i know the ropes a
little and uh i think you need a little
that if the treadmill is not on
you're not gonna run new york the
treadmill is on so it just makes you run
and it makes you better look it wears on
you you probably lose 10 years of your
life living in new york versus
uh you know indianapolis but
it's a you know it's a better life have
you seen 25th hour yeah
um spike lee joint yeah sparkly joy i
mean uh at norton
there's a there's a whole like monologue
there about
they're talking about
just he he has like a mix
it's there's like melancholy music i
think or just a melancholy feel to the
whole thing but there's an anger and a
disgust with the city but through the
anger and the disgust comes out like a
love for the city same with was taxi
driver in new york oh yeah
crazy
yeah so like that there's something
about what is that what is that that uh
grit
of the city
that
like
pushes you down well that's the beauty
of the city is it's this tribal human
nature like the
sex shops and fist fights and racism and
all tension but yet it's the epicenter
of technology and finance and
sophistication on fifth avenue so you
get that
juxtaposition
it's kind of like in boston you go to
boston they got mit they got harvard
they got all this [ __ ] and then they got
the fishermen the blue-collar douchebags
the irish guys the immigrants you know
and you get that mix of like insanely
smart with wicked pissa and these these
two worlds and that's that's a good
thing it's like when a black guy [ __ ]
an asian lady that's a good looking kid
you get a mix you know we're mixing two
totally different things they're coming
together and it makes it it's like
peanut butter and chocolate
peanut butter and chocolate i've never
tried that what peanut butter maybe i
haven't talked about reese's like
reese's
yeah yeah it's the best candy yeah
without the fakeness of la without the
without the kind of um
with the facade yeah at least tough
what's the difference between uh la
comedy new york comedy to you um
i think one place you kind of go to make
it and be discovered
and be loved and one place you go you
can you can get all that in new york too
but i think in new york it's more of a
a school a boot camp of comedy
let's make great comedy let's make
original comedy let's watch the other
guys and gals who are at the show at the
clubs and
learn from them and
try to hang out with them and absorb
some of them and in la it's like
when am i on i'm next get out of my way
i'm the star here
i'm a bigger star than you oh this guy's
actually a big star i gotta outwork you
know it's just a lot of that instead of
like damn that was funny i gotta be that
funny damn i wish i had a joke and look
i don't want to speak for la comics
because there's you know bill burr
anthony jeselnik this brilliant l.a
comic but they all cut their teeth in
new york just saying then they moved to
l.a
that's a good point ali wong all these
people killer comics but new york
started new york moved to new york
there is something about comics that
stay in new york for a long time though
like david towel ah you know about dave
yeah yeah he wants to do this podcast he
does yeah i'm a huge fan of david oh
yeah but it's like it almost like he
doesn't
want to make it
i don't know i mean you probably know
him but like
it feels like you just
maybe it's romanticizing it but you're
like
you almost just love the art of comedy
like becoming funnier crafting the jokes
becoming funnier than the other comics
like competing with each other kind of
thing not over like money or fame or any
of that just just purely the comedy of
it totally that's dave that's him in a
nudge he's like that guy in the movies
in the 80s action movies where they're
like they go up to a a creek in montana
and some guy's living in a cabin and
he's sharpening a stick and they go
the russians are coming they're invading
we need you you're the best commando and
he's like i gave that up man i'm done
with that lifestyle like well you're the
best we need you and he has to suit up
eventually you know he looks at a
picture of his dead wife and he goes
[ __ ] it i'm going and then they you know
fight the ruskies but uh he's that guy
he just is gifted he's like got a gift
from a la and he's the best
yeah a lot of comics give him props it's
always surprising to me i didn't because
surprising to me because
he hasn't really made it
like big he did in the 90s he was huge
he had his own tv show he was yeah yeah
that show that show was awesome but i
mean like as big as i think he deserves
to be so i well that's art the
mainstream [ __ ] is always the worst
it's like mcdonald's versus some hole in
the wall i know i'm [ __ ] on
mcdonald's again but
it's good and you know certain comics we
could name are good but
the the delicacy is going to be less
talked about and less uh household namey
than
than the mainstream
hacky [ __ ] yeah it's funny because he
hasn't uh i think he was on
uh joe rogan's show once maybe yeah once
again and he was with somebody else um
jeff raw yeah he met him with jeff ross
oh yeah because they did that like two
mikes thing with mike's yeah yeah
um but he's the quickest guy there's no
one funnier yeah
yeah yeah him and
you you're super quick get your
appearance on recent appearance on
roguelike solutions oh thanks just so
fast
you're wrong with the ari and
shane gillis shane gills yeah that was
fun we're going back in january yeah
this has never come out
neither will you
we're having fun yeah all right so what
does it feel like um
to bomb in stand-up comedy like to fail
maybe the psychology of it first like
just take me through it because you were
talking about being
uh outnumbered in a fight just being
beat up very similar
uh by the way this is like a no eye
contact off yeah
yeah yeah it's great it's kind of nice
to be with my people
um but yeah you guys should have paper
to look at her
i'm going
i got a good sweet spot right there yes
yeah it's a nightmare but it's part of
it you know it's it's
it's the it's the validation too is the
worst part like because you know
whenever you do comedy and kill you can
be a great comic but even david tell
these brilliant guys they feel like
they're getting you feel like you're
getting away with something i don't have
a day job i'm telling jokes for a living
i'm talking about my dick up here and
they're [ __ ] loving me and they call
me a genius and all this i'm talking
about my sack yeah you know and uh and
it's great it makes people happy and
it's funny but
uh that bombing when you bomb you go
your first thought is like yeah you're
right at first you're like
[ __ ] you guy what you don't like this
[ __ ] and then you just start going in
you're like yeah maybe it isn't that
good maybe they're right i do suck i
knew i sucked i should become a mailman
you know and uh it stinks and it feel
you feel alone and you feel like you
wasted their time and then you're like
what was i thinking i could be a
comedian what the [ __ ] who am i you know
eddie murphy what am i doing here so
it's a lot of just spiraling out of
horrible thoughts
but i also love that it hurts so bad
bombing [ __ ] hurts because now now
everybody doesn't do it i think a lot
more people could do comedy probably and
figure it out but the bombing is so
brutal that it keeps uh
one time i went to minneapolis i was
like this is a great city i mean the sun
is shining why isn't the city like
packed and they're like because the
winners are so bad and we love it
because it keeps everybody out and i
feel the same about comedy the bombs are
so brutal
i've had bombs where i'm in i'm in bed
i'm just staring at the ceiling like
what the [ __ ] was that like you have
ptsd i bombed at an arena once 20 000
people i did 30 minutes to silence
so it's not just like one joke
fails they start piling on like it's
irrecoverable yes and one joke failing
is very common like a lot of audience
don't even notice like that bomb because
you get you know you got so many jokes
in a row you can sandwich a good one
then a bad one then a good one but when
you bomb it's almost like they chose we
don't like you
nothing you say will redeem yourself
and uh it's hard to get out of it's like
being pulled down by your hair you can't
get back i can't win this fight no
matter what
can you like get him back by
acknowledging
like the alpha in the room that like
that helps but they're still gonna go
and that was funny when he made fun of
it but he sucks he's still so he still
sucks that's the worst part you're going
no this is good you guys just don't like
me just because you don't like me
doesn't mean i'm bad
yeah i like going to open mics a lot
just just listening because
first of all i think the audience and
open mic at least the ones i've been to
is uh mostly i guess other comedians
it's it or like at least people who
don't seem to want to laugh at anything
and so
i just love it because it's human nature
and perseverance that is best that
here's comedians like clearly
uh this is mostly in austin they have a
dream like why would you get up there
right
like maybe some weird you know
new year's resolution [ __ ] but for
the most part it's people who want to be
comedian like a lot of the open mikers
are people who clearly have done this
for quite a long time
like at least a year two maybe five
years
and
they're often not very funny
and um
the just
bombing in front of
an audience of like 20 where they're
just sitting there
like
almost like mocking them with their eyes
or maybe
and i don't know and they still push
through they still they still like as if
they're doing an arena and everybody's
laughing yeah they still they still got
that energy trying almost like to an
audience
that doesn't exist like an audience of
their dreams because i guess you have to
do that to keep the energy of the act
going and it's just so beautiful to
watch wow then try it it's uh and also
the what happens
open mic i don't know five minutes
whatever they do
they you know walk off and that walk
back you know off stage
and like you can't who do they look at
like what do you look at do you make eye
contact with people do you you look at
your phone you look at your feet you
just zone out you kind of
kind of go white you know you just hear
white noise and go out it's it's tough
but you got it you need a little
a little delusion to be a comedian to
get into it it takes a little bit of
delusion like you think you can do this
you know you got 10 years ahead of you
of hell and you're up for this
and you know most comics we see a
horrible crowd and we see our friend
bomb and we go yeah he's bombing but
i'll get him i'll get him and then
you don't get them
but
that's that's
human nature too is like i they don't
like him but they'll like me and you
need a little of that to keep going as a
comedian but you don't want too much
delusion because then you're a psycho
but
you need a little well a psycho could be
good for a comedy that's true too a lot
of psychos i mentioned to you offline um
that i talked to elon and we talked
about doing stand-up that he's thinking
maybe do a few minutes of stand up say
if you need a coach elon i gotcha
um well maybe you should move to austin
to coach him full time ah i hope he can
fly me in
so
what what advice would you give to
somebody who um who wants to try to do
five minutes like the early steps
of uh trying to go to an open mic and
say something funny well that's the
irony of comedy is i don't know if it's
irony but it's like the beginning is the
hardest part usually the beginning is
the easy part hey i'm playing this level
of mario i'd start jump over one koopa
troopa whatever and then the end is like
jesus christ i got 30 guys coming at me
comedy is the opposite the beginning is
like
it's a gauntlet it's just obstacles and
it's like you said open mics you i watch
these famous comedians on netflix and
you go this would all bomb on an open
mic they're killing in you know radio
city this would bomb it open mike that's
the weird part so it's almost you have
to go through hell just to get
to the
promised land and uh i would say
rehearse the [ __ ] out of it because
you're gonna get frazzled up there
everybody thinks oh this is good
material but you also forget about the
other part of delivering it having
confidence
being likable having timing having a
cadence figuring out who you are figure
out what the audience thinks you are or
how they perceive you because you can go
up there and say all this but they go
why's the guy he's clearly gay why is he
acting like he's not gay you know that's
all now they're not listening to the
joke so like you got to know how you
look and uh it's just repetition
repetition and bombing is not failure
that's what you got to remember i mean
look if you if you do a a killer hour
and then you take it to netflix and bomb
you [ __ ] up but
bombing is not failure it's just data
it's going oh okay i gotta re retool
that that didn't work something's wrong
there they i missed a word there so you
gotta treat the uh the act almost like
uh
like uh like ingredients in a
cooking and a dish you know like oh that
i put too many eggs in take an egg out
you got to treat it like that and look
when you pull a bad cake out of an oven
you go i [ __ ] up but it doesn't hurt
your feelings but when you bomb and [ __ ]
up it hurts your feelings so you gotta
factor that in too your feeling's gonna
be hurt and just almost be a robot and
just keep going towards that open mic
you know how scary an open mic is
bombing sucks but bombing in front of
other comedians is way worse because
they know what just happened and they
could have saved you and they didn't
so it's way worse
and that they're going to be your
quote-unquote friends
for this journey yeah no these are evil
people
twisted [ __ ] up
work people
can you tell like in those early days
let's just talk about that like at the
open mic level that a joke is going to
be good on paper like i'll give you my
experience because uh
um maybe you can be my coach in this
particular moment so uh larry nasser
that's fun huh
joking everybody i hope nobody thinks
seriously
uh there's i now have an amazing team of
folks who help me with editing and
they're now currently sweating
you gotta leave that one yeah that was
quick yeah that's pretty good i'll eat
that one that was good
[Laughter]
all right so
uh you know uh going in front of an
audience just even to give a lecture
terrifies me uh
which which i've done
but uh open mic i mean that to me
perhaps that's why i like going to open
mics and listening is cause i just
it terrifies me so much that idea yeah
of
going up there and bombing i mean it's
scary and to do even like one minute to
be honest is scary in five minutes
i'm also watching enough open mics to
realize that five minutes is a long time
i mean it depends on your comedy
but if you're doing fast
stuff five minutes is a really long time
oh it's eternity um i guess it was a
long story
two is a long time because if the
story's not work you're building up to
something if the story is gonna fail you
just spent all that time telling the
story that completely went flat
completely got nothing i guess if you
have a series of jokes you can at least
try to recover and like do the mitch
hedberg thing where like all right i'll
cross that off yeah yeah
uh well i'm able to like i've tried to
write a few things and i'm able to tell
that it's really bad
well that's better than most
most people's egos kick and they go no
this is good no see i'm able to
introspect that like it seems funny i
mean i guess the thing i'm looking for
is original
like
there's easy stuff
that you think is funny but to me
originality is the thing you should be
looking for because then because then
that's what's actually
becomes funny like
or rather if it's original
even if it bombs that feels like more a
beautiful art creation that you did like
at least you swung for it like you did
something unique because like even with
open mic your first five minutes there's
so many just go to enough open mics
you'll hear like all the there's like a
list of jokes that you just go to first
of all you can make fun of the fact that
you're at open mic that you're like
doing this the first time and so on you
could do a lot of stuff where you make
fun of your appearance in some way yeah
and so on but like yeah you could do
that
you know
that takes actually that's way harder
than people realize to do it in an
original way yes to present
who you are as a person
very quickly enough to then
put that person down in front of
everybody else so you have to reveal the
audiences like that because they go he
knows what we're thinking yeah exactly
but do it again in an original way and
so like when i'm trying to write stuff
not that i've tried long it's like 30
minutes but as
enough to see like oh [ __ ] the to write
something original is really difficult
it is what do you you got a bit anything
no you didn't write any one line or
anything for this no well just in
general ever in your life ever written a
joke oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay no
but i don't have anything in my mind
popped up so the
the the jokes that i've written
have more like for some reason my mind
goes to like dark places so you know
like
and not actually dark in the mark norman
dark because you go
really dark
to where it's like almost absurd yeah my
natural inclination is to go to like
a dark
historical like place like hitler and
stalin yeah and almost
so go to that place
and then
talk about something absurd
there
so like don't go like uh
like all the way i don't know i don't
want to give examples because it would
be clipped but the
but the mark norma style look it up he
has a special on his youtube
uh
that kind i i want to almost explore the
dark aspects of human nature more kind
of
uh connected to actual historical
figures that's the
that's the inclination like i don't know
nature's metal the the instagram channel
that that explores like the darkness of
nature
like something there
see that's good that you already know
that
you've kind of gotten to the core of
your comedy already and that that's
interesting that's a step ahead
yeah i can hear i mean with most things
i do in life i can like hear the music
from a distance like in myself like okay
if you have anything this is the
direction it'll be yeah without actually
knowing exactly all the steps and that's
the nice motivation to be like all right
well if you do this for a long time
maybe you'll have a chance to get there
right but you have to i that that's
where the it's a feature to be super
self-critical i think yes but then
that's why it's [ __ ] terrifying to
walk up to the stage stand there
and probably forget everything yeah
that's the other part nobody thinks
about just goes right out of your head
you go fight or flight it's ugly my
first years were horrific bombing
horrific stammering horrific not
remembering the punch line like you got
maybe you got a setup going and they're
kind of on board and you're like ah
how's that camera camera how it goes and
you just
hate yourself it's it's a nightmare but
you've already kind of
maybe if you haven't done stand-up or
whatever but you kind of know your voice
and that's
yeah that's pretty advanced so you're
not trying to be somebody else i guess
yeah just for having done like podcasts
and lecturing and so on that helps you
i've embarrassed i already done some of
the work of the stand-ups do which is
embarrass yourself in front of others
for long periods of time yes yeah so
i've done that without actually
developing the funny right right right
but maybe the funny just is not that
difficult to develop
um no it's super difficult of course but
i mean maybe the essential work of a
stand-up comedian is just the
embarrassment of like finding who you
are yeah that's a part of it for sure
you know in the beginning you're like
water bottle what's funny about water
bottle i'm a funny guy i can make this
money but that ain't that's not it you
know it's it's your [ __ ] your [ __ ] like
your dark stuff for me
i tend to gravitate towards dark but in
a weird way where
you know people say like hey don't
objectify women but then they go caitlyn
jenner's beautiful and you're like well
wait
i know something's off here why can you
objectify her
but not the supermodel so what's going
on there and i like to play with that
so i have this joke where i say uh
caitlyn jenner
oh women go caitlyn jenner's beautiful
beautiful woman i go well you look like
her and they go [ __ ] you
and you're like there's a lot of truth
there yeah but i like exploring that
kind of
oh you're trying to get one over on me
or you're lying to yourself or what are
we doing here and i like i like that
kind of comedy
i don't see color well i'm black no
you're not ah
you know that's fun because you're
you're lying
uh yeah okay so
like big time comedians such as yourself
don't like to think of yourself in this
way but here we go yeah this is like
where you overfill philosophize comedy
but
yeah definitely it seems like
comedians
don't say important nothing worse than a
comedian who thinks they're important
yeah so i was going there i was trying
to find as i was trying to say these
words i read
realize how cliche it is and how
uninteresting it is so i'm going to just
but there is something uh i'm worried
this whole thing is uninteresting i'm
like who cares about comedy and there's
like six comics on the planet but nobody
cares okay this is just i trust you in
the in the pilot seat you know what
you're doing you got you got listeners
they've tuned out long ago
dan carlin on here huh is he around yeah
we're just going back and forth on
twitter just now because i'm a huge fan
he was on here before he'll be back
i've been actually really
uh trying to volunteer myself
aggressively with dan carlin for
for like a russian episode where i could
speak russian i there's there's certain
documents same i talked with jocko about
this too
certain things
i mean i just love the challenge of
bringing russian documents that i can
read in russian and they can translate
and can
try to capture the uh the depth
of the writing
in um in the russian language and
communicate to the american audience so
much is lost in translation like there's
so much pain and poetry in the russian
language it's just connected to the
culture every language not every
language but
many languages are
uniquely able to capture the culture of
the people i mean in some way there's a
representation of the culture of the
people
and so russian is definitely that it
like represents the full history and
culture of the 20th century with all the
atrocities all the
all the broken promises all those kinds
of things norm says uh russian
literature is
it's the most tapped into human
existence than anything else
uh norm mcdonald yeah big big russian
literature guy dostoyevsky all that [ __ ]
it's funny that there is a gap with
comedians too there's a culture of
russian comedy uh like stand-up
comedians that are told
yeah yeah i don't know these russians
i mean uh i don't know today and oh i
mean more from the 80s and 90s and
there's a yakov
that's all i know
that's not so there's like of course
that's that's
i've never seen that offended no no it's
not if and there's a different uh
there's there's a there's like the
kinnisons and the
there's the edgy is that russian
what do you mean wait i thought you said
there was russian comics yeah russian i
mean i'm comparing that i'm giving you
that i'm giving you like a style of
darkness uh like that's the kind the
people that kind of challenge
uh
they give again this is to how important
comedians are is they give a voice to
people where in the soviet union you
really can't like express your
opposition to the government and so
comedians are exceptionally
important there
for
just just i don't know channeling the
anger even when sometimes it's not the
actual opposition to the government
they're just channeling the anger the
frustration with the absurdity of life
like
you know when there's a shortage of food
shortage of jobs the the
the absurdity of the bureaucracy like
the a top-heavy government
just
all of that can only sometimes be
expressed with like dark absurd humor
and that actually why there's a culture
of that kind of humor
you know you gather on the table with
vodka yeah and all you can do is just
talk [ __ ] yep and just
be offensive say horrible [ __ ] ball bust
i mean i make school shooting jokes and
people go how do you do that i'm like
well maybe that's how i deal with it
yeah you know like how come i gotta
i gotta
empathize the way you do maybe we're
different
all right so now let's skip the whole
open mic thing and
crafting jokes
that's tough
kerouac said
one day i will find the right words and
they will be simple
when do you know the joke is done it's
perfect
you're somebody that does like
really sharp like
fast
uh jokes wow thanks
so like there's somebody
i don't know i don't know who you see
yourself in the same school as like
had your
you're darker and faster than hedberg i
think in terms of like
just i don't know the turns you take it
very fast
hey thanks i appreciate it i think i got
some norm mcdonald and maybe that's
right you know
obviously norm but uh chris rock was
huge for me chris old like 90s chris
rock was like
i didn't know you could do jokes like
that i always loved george carlin and
groucho marx and bill murray there's so
many different types of comedy but uh
when i saw the bigger and blacker bring
the pain i was like
oh my god this like it hit me
so that was big and then norm's just
like the funniest guy on the planet so
him him being the smartest guy in the
room but acting dumb was great
so uh
yeah chris rock has that way of cutting
to the
the [ __ ] which i i mentioned earlier
i like that cutting through the [ __ ]
kind of style of comedy because you kind
of go oh i'm not crazy that's what i
thought too i was too scared to say but
i thought that and he's saying in a room
of people are laughing
maybe i'm not an idiot
so that helped me
so it's
observational but not
jerry science
observational it's like look going to
the darker thing yeah like like wasn't
great but
i like him too but seeing it doing it
about stuff like
in your life society yeah race gender
government yes politics all that kind of
stuff exactly exactly sex human emotions
jealousy whatever it is that that's the
good stuff
how'd you feel when norm passed away ah
that was a bummer because uh he was you
know what 61
and i just didn't see it coming and i
just i've watched so many hours of his
stuff and i i've met him and he he's
like
he was like this comedic bar like hey we
got norm you know there's so much [ __ ]
comedy then you see norm and you're like
this is next level this is savant type
[ __ ] and then to lose him is like ah
norm had
20 more years at least of just content
and content and thoughts and his point
of view and that's we'll never get that
that sucks
yeah there is something about artists
like jimi hendrix dying yeah too early
it's like you wonder
what was next yeah what was next but
then part of it is like
um you know it all ends for all of us
and it's like walking away early
is um
it's kind of admirable it's almost like
i did a pretty good job yeah i'm uh i'm
i'm good with that and especially the
way he did which is not telling anybody
i know
nine years his best friends didn't even
know and in this world of like
victimhood and i need clicks and i need
people to love me he could have he got
you know cancelled and yelled at in
trouble and he could have pulled that
cancer card and he never did i mean the
integrity on this [ __ ] did you
get a chance to interact with him like
what how many how often did you meet him
i met him once at the comedy cellar and
we chatted for five minutes and then he
went on and did the the letterman set
that he did he was running the letterman
set and uh
sweet guy nice guy didn't know him that
well but i mean he's just brilliant and
i also love a brilliant guy who does
stupid stuff
that's a fun
fun little combo there like silly guys
who are actually brilliant also
you know like louis ck is a brilliant
comic and he'll do a a joke about
farting on a kid and you're like that's
great that he still
finds farts funny and he's also this
comedic genius guy i like that
and doesn't really acknowledge the
genius yeah
yeah that's
yeah i like i like smart people they're
silly yes that's a good combo like you
said elon is silly yeah yeah that's
great yeah because we we taught we teach
kids like hey put that down stop that
quit cutting up quit horsing around but
maybe that's some kind of sign of
brilliance there yeah
being like childlike and silly is a kind
of wisdom i feel like those people are
way wiser than the people that
no offense to me wear a suit and take
themselves way too seriously no but you
got a spark in you a little here you got
a little uh what's the word
not elf
imp
little imp in yeah give that a goog you
know what imp uh yeah
it's like a little uh said uh uh tolkien
character imp yeah my name is european
mythological being similar to a fairy or
are you calling me a fairy
frequently no okay similar to a fairy or
a demon
i feel like that's a big leap big leap
yeah that's not a great uh info bio
there frequently described in folklore
and superstition the word may perhaps
derive from the term
imp spell with the y
used to denote a young grafted tree
oh
it's a little mischievous you got a
twinkle you're the serious buttoned up
guy but this is a twinkle as a twinkle
wow and the audience can see the twinkle
and that's why you resonate i think
i'm sorry deep analysis by mark norman
psychological analysis okay but then
back to the crafting of the joke you
said chris rock and norma mcdonald like
what for you
um how do you know when the joke is like
done is are there some jokes or you're
like are proud of like wow that
that's uh that's well done yeah yeah the
joke is done it's a tough question
because there's so many different kinds
of jokes that's what we call a chunk
which is a big idea with a bunch of
jokes in the middle of it and then a big
crescendo at the end or there's a
one-liner or there's a tag of a joke
that's also a joke so
the jokes come in different uh like i
have a joke where i say i met my girl in
that jewish app what's that jewish app
called uh
paypal
nice
that's the hell that's the reaction you
want from the crowd but
it's a fun turn because you say your
thing and then i hit you with a
misdirect and that's what a joke is a
joke is basically me saying something
that makes sense but you didn't see it
coming yeah and that's a perfect example
of that so uh that joke took forever to
figure out by the way you know and you
have to go through different services
like paypal okay
what's funniest exactly and i figured
paypal is funny because it has the word
pay in it yeah you know venmo it's also
not really a good work venmo paypal it
just hits better yeah paypal is funnier
somehow it's funnier and that's the
beauty of com there's a weird little
magic into it you can get technical all
day and formulaic but there's still that
little bit of uh fairy dust that you
don't know why this is funnier
or imp dust imp dust
yes the why
okay so you know what joke is done when
it kills and if this is a roundness to a
joke when you feel like this is buttoned
up this is done here yeah is simplicity
the right word there
yeah is it like you're chopping stuff
away are you adding stuff like what does
it feel like simplicity is always the
best
angle i mean you can get real high
concept with a joke and still make it
work but the simpler the better i saw uh
dave chappelle on stage once and chris
rock and dimitri martin were in the back
watching in awe and dave schweller i
can't remember the joke but he said
something about sex or women
and demetri martin goes that's a little
easy and chris rock goes that's why it's
good and i remember hearing that as some
young comic like ah
i'm getting this like you know comedy
lesson right here from these two titans
and so that was fun
simple is key so the easy's okay that's
such a weird uh i
i think i remember um
reading or hearing eminem say something
about maybe the song some [ __ ] one of
the songs
he's like i knew it was going to be good
because
it got like really repetitive and
annoying very quickly
i mean that's the the sort of the music
equivalent of um
it's too easy like if it's like super
catchy
as a musician you might get
very quickly bored of it right or like
as you're creating it now it's too it's
too easy
it's like there needs to be some more
complexity to it but i like complexity
but the best guys who
are the ones who make complex [ __ ] look
simple
like you ever heard that uh
ben franklin story where he's talking to
his friend his friends like i'm gonna
start a hat store so he puts a sign out
says
hats for sale 12 and and ben frank looks
at it goes uh well you don't need the
twelve dollars because you know all they
need to know is that you got hats for
sale he's like all right so he loses to
twelve dollars makes a new sign hats for
sale and he goes you know you don't
really need for sale because it's a
business people can put that together so
he just goes all right he makes a new
sign it says hats and then ben
franklin's like
you know you don't really need the word
hat you can just put a picture of a hat
and he made a new sound which is a
picture of a hat and like help the
business or something that's like some
old wives tale or whatever but i think
about that all the time when i'm writing
i thought this was going to like there
was no sign it went like super like
that could work too
uh
what
like as a comedian so i'm a fan of yours
i enjoy i really enjoy you in
conversations like wow because you're
now i'm getting nothing out of it this
is
all right i can't tell like emotion
you're tough not to read cold inside
i mean just the quickness you have
obviously you're also a great stand-up
comedian what's your favorite medium
to shine in so you have a podcast
yourself an excellent podcast
um
you're often a podcast guest yeah
which is always fun to listen to how
you're going to deal with the different
people you're great on rogan oh thank
you um
what what do you enjoy most podcasts are
great because you can you can stretch
out a little more you can breathe a
little you know with a stand-up set i
like to be like boom boom boom boom boom
but podcasts are great because
it's conversational so you can be it's
almost like you're being funny with your
friends yeah whereas the stage is like a
this is a piece this is a presentation
uh but i think the the podcast is great
but you don't get the reaction unless
the host is laughing you can't hear the
guy in his car in new jersey driving to
work going ah
every now and then i'll read a comment
like i spit out my coffee when you said
this and i'm like
but it's not immediate you want the
immediate so stand up will always be
number one but there's no better feeling
than killing in a room of people who
don't know who you are strangers you're
in the middle of nowhere you left your
wife at home you left your kids you left
your house you're in the middle of bum
[ __ ] dickville and murdering for these
hillbilly nobody whatever it is
and they're slinging their beers and
cheering you on and they carry out and
you [ __ ] some fat lady and you leave and
you get back to your hotel and you go
holy [ __ ] what was that no one will ever
know about it just lost in the ether
that's the best feeling
yeah
killing an obscurity as bill burr would
say
yeah this is one of the things that
sucks about giving lectures
like
at universities or giving lectures in
general is when you look at
the audience you know several hundred
students
they're all have a bored look on their
face
like even like my my face now probably
looks bored but i'm actually excited to
be talking to you but there's something
about just uh
there's something about a comedy called
maybe this the contingent of laughter
but like it gives people the freedom to
just laugh to like
to remove that facade of like you don't
have to you don't have to pretend
like you don't care like if you care you
can show it and yeah have fun with it
probably liquor is helpful too yeah it
helps for sure but there is a especially
and that's why comedy i think is so
popular right now because
hr is up our ass we're scared of old
tweets that might come back to haunt us
what did i say on that interview uh even
people at offices are like i put
something on facebook in
1999 that was about fat tits that i
liked should i get rid of that
even people say like there's no cancel
whatever
there is something in the air right now
and that wasn't there before yeah it's
the video i i'm a karen i got caught at
trader joe whatever it is this people
rat on each other now everybody's
tattletailing because they want the
clicks it's a horrible
society we've crafted but
stand-up comedy gets you to come out and
now people do it at stand-up shows too
sadly but it gets you to come out and
let that inhibition down like because
we're all human we've all had the [ __ ]
up thoughts like man that guy's fat as
[ __ ] you don't mean you hate the guy
that mean you hate fat people then
you're fat shaming but you can't say
that at the office you can't go pop
you're fat as [ __ ] you'll get fired for
body shaming but at the club you go that
guy's fat as [ __ ] the crowd goes he is
bad as [ __ ]
and it's this weird cathartic thing
because all we do is tamp [ __ ] down it's
kind of like you ever meet a girl who's
like all prim and proper in the bedroom
she's like put a lamp up my ass ah you
know whatever it is it's cause
we gotta get it out we're all repressed
in some way
so i guess what you're saying is uh
comedy's important
[Laughter]
yes
call back all right well played sir yeah
what do you think about austin what do
you think about the comedy scene austin
talk about l.a in new york
what do you think about what joe's
trying to create there so i i i should
say that the reason i moved to austin i
have this dream of uh wouldn't be funny
if i said this dream of becoming a
comedian oh yeah
an audience at least yeah that's true
you know i always said you can hear the
music in the distance i you know i have
this dream around robotics and
artificial intelligence whether it's a
company whether it's something else that
uh it was just pulling me to do i
actually wanted to move to san francisco
and then all my friends in san francisco
said no it's the wrong place yeah to to
uh it's no it's at this time the the the
cynicism there
is just not conducive to like
taking big leaps into the unknown
excited about the future kind of thing
and and austin was that uh with um for
me in particular with elon musk but also
just the energy that everybody had
including joe the excitement about the
future
i don't i don't care if austin burns to
the ground and it actually is a complete
failure yeah uh being excited about the
future
seems to be like optimism about the
future it seems to be the thing
that actually makes that future happen
it makes a great future happen so it's
always cool for me to see
uh like joe
super excited about creating like a
a culture in austin like a
making it a comedy hub like yeah i don't
want to overstate it but he i mean i
think he really believes it'll be a very
big place for comedy yeah in the united
states in general in the world and so
just even believing that that's powerful
like
you start to make it you start to make
it happen that energy uh is there anyway
so but that's for me from just an
outsider watching uh the fun of i should
also mention
for less of an outsider more insider in
the martial arts world
partially probably because of joe i'm
not sure like john donahue
gordon ryan the b team all those folks
those are that might be gibberish to you
but those are like some of the greatest
grapplers and martial artists of all
time so it's also becoming this hub
of martial arts so the whole the whole
thing is just beautiful anyway what uh
what are your thoughts about that scene
well there's a lot a lot here a lot of
things to mention one i think joe
did do that to at a degree you know like
all these people segora lives there now
a lot of comics live there he's opening
clubs other clubs are opening
i think it's happening that's the other
thing is people go everybody's moving to
austin austin's the new hub and then
they look at their watch and they go
five minutes went by nothing changed
it's gonna take
years you know but everybody wants it
now now now
um what awesome there's no
industry there you know there's no
netflix whatever and you're like yeah i
know but it needs a minute you can't
just do this overnight so people forget
that so it could happen huge just give
it some time i mean he's opening a club
i went and saw it it's incredible like
it's so perfect for comedy it's every
detail it's incredible but uh
so
it could happen still i do think
where there's a little biting off more
than they can chew with austin because
it's not that big so it's gonna spread
out i mean yeah it's not big and the
infrastructure is not quite exactly to
support it
but it has a lot of uh you know i'm
comparing for my from the tech side
for uh it has a lot of land to expand
into so it might become this that helps
like you're basically establishing it's
kind of like when new york you're
establishing these whole neighborhoods
yeah and you have the freedom to do that
because
there's a lot of space on all sides yes
okay so that helps so again maybe some
time
uh
i do agree with this that new hope
that's kind of built into human beings
of like let's go to america let's go to
utopia we even have it with space let's
go to mars we gotta see what's over
there and it's just red dusty [ __ ]
but you still gotta go
so i'm with you on that about this new
hope this new land
uh and i think that is beautiful and i
think there's a lot of haters and
there's a lot of naysayers who hate
change who hate anything new and then i
think you got to go hey that hurts that
sucks but blow me [ __ ] i'm trying
something you're a loser
stop hating on me
i mean how many people hate elon musk
you know yeah it's hilarious i mean
there's uh some of the criticism on
austin it would be it's like a fad like
a lot of people are really yeah yeah i
really people are excited about austin
and somehow that's like uh it's like
when green day became famous you no
longer want to
be a fan of green day but to me like
this uh
austin was already a cool town like
every comic five years ago was like oh i
got austin this weekend i can't wait
yeah so it already had a buzz but
some people think maybe the buzz was the
cool part the fact that it was like this
off the beaten path city
and now i get to visit it and then leave
but i think it could still be this
comedy tech booming place it just will
take some time and people want it right
now
well on the tech side
it's
uh it's already there it's it's it's
getting there very fast so i mean elon's
really pushing that with the factory
it's just a huge number of people are
moving there with jobs like you're
already starting and then the
opportunities to launch new companies is
just incredible i guess it's not right
now it's like within months within a
year that kind of thing but like it's an
opportunity to just
start to
build [ __ ] in a new place and it's cool
it's kind of like you know going to mars
it's like you get to start over yeah and
i like the hope aspect i think that's
huge for people
and uh
i'm all for it i hope it works out i
don't know if it will but i don't know
anything about economies and city scans
planning and all that [ __ ] so
it might be too early to say but i hope
it works
are you still talking about austin or
mars austin mars is uh
there's nothing there there's no vagina
there there's no food there there's no
water there i don't know it seems i get
space travel i think it's important but
i
i don't know mars is really gonna
move the needle
so what are your thoughts about uh elon
musk and spacex and launching rockets
into space i think it's all good because
you could say hey we could just feed
everybody and i was like yeah that's
true by the way these guys give a ton of
money to like philanthropy [ __ ] that
nobody cares about
by the way you know it's weird like he
can feed the
nigeria and with pocket change of his
and you're like well maybe he has
you know like i heard bill gates gave
back so much money he saved six million
lives yeah but that's a reverse
holocaust by the way that's pretty good
what have you done you're a barista
so uh
you know i just think uh
i think space travel is good because you
learn
about the place you're living in from
going to space
it kind of helps you learn about this
more
you could say what's the point of going
to this other there but it it does help
i think yeah doing difficult things in
the engineering space seems to be a way
to develop like as a
as almost like an accident as a side
effect of doing a really difficult thing
in a team of brilliant people you
develop things like the internet and you
could argue that the internet maybe is
not so good for society no i'm just
kidding that's good and bad yeah but
it's like a pull-up you're trying to get
your bicep going but hey before you know
you got decent forearms but you weren't
working on the forearms you wanted to
buy but you got the four and i think
that's kind of what space travel is
i like how this like pivoted into uh to
a out routine advice wow we're trying to
get uh an analogy going here all right
it worked pretty well i'll take it all
right
what are your thoughts about
since i'm a robotics person i'd be
curious to see like what um
you think about the space at all about
first of all autonomous vehicles with uh
tesla autopilot and
uh waymo
self-driving car i'm not sure if you're
familiar with all the autonomous
vehicles and so on so those are robots
on wheels and then there's also legged
robots so next time you're in austin you
get to meet some of the legged robots
i've
been working on
and i find those kind of um
a fascinating way to explore
the nature of intelligence in our
computers but also explore our own
intelligence and also explore our own um
like what makes us connect to other
living beings whether it's dogs cats or
other humans like there's some magic
there
that's beyond just intelligence and i
like when i have the robot dog there's
some aspect to it
that
i don't know brings me joy in a way that
a dog does in a way that a good friend
does yeah that's interesting and i'm not
sure if that's some kind of
anthropomorphism like where i'm
projecting right my hopes for this what
this thing is but maybe a little of that
but it's kind of built in i mean it's
just a source of joy maybe it it's
connected to the fact that there's just
like a loneliness within all of us
within me and it's just nice to have
other
things in your life
that move that recognize you that kind
of thing i mean i suppose it's nice to
even just have a plant
yeah it is plant goes a long way you see
a guy with plants in the department it
changes the apartment because they're
alive you got to water them you got to
put sun on them so yeah i think there's
something there and i think you can see
people's reactions when you show them
advanced technology like these dog
robots or these robots that dance and
[ __ ] people are like what the [ __ ] like
it hits home in some way whether it's
fear or or you want to [ __ ] them clearly
whatever it is but it does connect with
you in some way
so uh i'm with you and i think this is
why i don't think robots will take over
you always say that robot they're making
them too advanced they're going to wipe
us out blah blah blah
if robots get human emotions
that is scary because they could they
could get mad at us and kill us and
they're stronger they don't need sleep
they don't need food they don't need
water
they don't get jealous they don't you
know but if they have
emotions then i think we can dominate
them because who's that emotion who
knows emotions better than us we've got
thousands of years of evolutionary
emotional [ __ ] we can go hey robot i
heard you uh your wife [ __ ] that black
and decker huh they're gonna crumble
we can bully them
emotionally manipulate robots yes that's
when we'll win
right now they could kill us they could
just
we'd all die then we shoot them back
bing bing bing bing that's no good but
if they do get emotions then we can
go hey you look like hell what is that a
rusty bolt hey you're dropping some oil
there you know you lose her i think we
can win if we if they do get emotions
this goes back to your father being able
to undercut you with a single word
you're right yeah so we're the creators
of the robots and then the robots will
just you you would say the the exact
thing yeah where the robot would be like
that son of a [ __ ] and then he goes
back to his hole and just sits there
miserable right yeah hardware looks more
like software to me you can't get it up
yadda yadda
yeah but i'm not worried about robots
and i think self what do you think about
the self-driving cars is that just
wiping out the horse and buggy isn't
that just progression of technology
yeah so i don't know if you've driven in
a tesla for example i have i've i wrote
in the uh the passage
yeah there's several stages in that i
think it's the problems way harder than
people realize
and for quite a while it'll just make
driving more pleasant it'll make it less
stressful it'll take over some of the
boring bits for you
and make it easier like there's
something that happens actually when the
car
is driving for you in the following way
like it's it's staying in the lane it's
keeping distance to the car in front of
you maybe it's changing lanes
it allows you to relax a little bit like
yes you become
you still have to be alert but you
become like a passenger and you get to
like take in the world i mean somehow
that's more relaxing without making you
necessarily
like
bored more it's energized anymore so i
just think it makes the driving
experience more pleasant
but when you actually fully automate
cars when you can just completely tune
out start reading a book or go to sleep
that might change
society
like in ways we don't even understand
because you'll have
i mean the the
they'll probably change the nature of
roads because the cars because now you
can be super productive
and so it no longer quite matters to you
as much how long it takes to get from
point a to point b
because you're not wasting that time
you're just continue working yeah it's
like public transit that comes to you
exactly
and
so they there will be maybe less roads
and bigger roads and it'll just change
the nature of how we get from point a to
point b i think you're right but that
then couple that also with the fact that
we seem to be more and more comfortable
existing in the digital world yeah
so like maybe we won't want to go
outside more and more we'll just
interact with each other virtually and i
don't mean zoom meetings i mean just
in other ways
that's uh that's
that's more fulfilling than a zoom
meeting there's but then maybe not
because like there's something deeply
uncompelling about
about zoom meetings like podcasts that
are remote
unless they're super information dense
at least to me as a podcast fan kind of
suck they suck there's no connect it
goes back to the dog thing with the zoom
there's no connection
yeah and we're not you know i i don't
understand why they're we're not even
making eye contact no it's but it's just
something there it's in the room there's
pheromones and that's like
out of our understanding probably it's
just some kind of weird biological
you know you ever have cheerios in a
bowl the cheerios tend to
they tend to go together you see a
cluster of cheerios they're never really
hanging out on the other side and that's
kind of how
people are in the industry real life i
wonder what the physics of that is so
they they come together and they stick
especially with molecules yeah i don't
know i camera what it was but it was
fascinating and i think that's how
people are and i think you try to write
a tv show or or craft a movie with your
team
zoom
not nothing there it's like phone sex
versus penetration
one day you'll learn that i i know
nothing of either the i look forward
because i think there's the phone sex
netflix documentary
there's a show or something like that
that uh is really populated i want to go
watch at least i can learn about that
okay i could send you some links
like really on the internet yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah self-driving car i think it's
just inevitable it's coming and these
truckers are gonna have to figure
something out
yeah i mean that's that's an understood
industry actually because there's not uh
there's a lot of trucking jobs oh yeah
and people don't want to well people
don't actually take them anymore because
it's such a difficult job so
it won't have or a lot of people believe
it won't have as big of a negative
impact as folks anticipate oh good
there'll be other automation i think
they'll have a huge impact yeah for sure
i mean you already see it in mcdonald's
you go to the people why do you want to
get yelled at by the uh heavyset woman
of color you know for making a bad order
when you can just you know hit the
screen
but those interactions i think
are human i mean that's part of life so
it is scary taking away everything how
long till we're not [ __ ]
that's coming too yeah then there's
gonna have two two types of people are
you uh uh [ __ ] in real life are you a
digital [ __ ] person i'm a digital i like
real [ __ ] sorry we can't date that's
coming well there's also the the
reproduction side of sex which is like
with genetic engineering
you'll be able to specify a little bit
of
details i talked to uh jamie martial
about that like where you can
um
specify like
what you know uh
it'll start with like i want my child
not to have
like a high likelihood of diabetes or
something like that
and then you get to specify like
intelligence you just get to specify
those kinds of parameters until
you're like
basically trying to create a perfect
human and you lose some of the magic of
the flaws that make us who we are yes
and you know i
i'm pretty sure in the full lineup of
humans
like the so
let me uh give you some information
i'm sure break it down i'm sure i'm sure
you researched uh this thoroughly but
uh a
a male of the human species of the homo
sapien
uh produces 500 billion
sperm cells in a lifetime
so that's all
uh some more than others
that's all
uniquely genetically unique humans that
you could produce so even across those
500 billion you can select
and so i mean like abort some
or no you can choose which of them you
want i mean just imagine all the genetic
possibilities that are there like all
the possible like you won
the race
yes
uh shocking this is yeah this is the
ball the 500 billion you have to imagine
what the competition was oh just tards
all day long handicap
well so it's not actually the the
fastest sperm or like it it's i think a
lot of his timing and luck
uh what it seems like there's actual
papers on this and i've actually been
reading them i hope so so it's not just
like the fastest sperm to the egg okay
there's a timing thing
so you were just lucky all right i i
believe that so it's interesting to
think about like once you're able to
specify
some parameters of what your child is
like
how that changes the nature of um
even just like
the intimacy of two humans getting
together
and making
creating together a child yeah i mean it
changes it
it's almost like uh i don't know it
becomes like a factory
line of some kind
if you don't meet naturally yeah if you
don't mean natural
and then you don't and you get you get
to optimize your child
then it's yeah then it's something like
you have to consider utilitarian type of
things like
what's good for society and it'll
probably be regulation about what kind
of children you can have or not like
your child cannot have an iq below this
or above us or something
your child cannot we already kind of do
that we know
vip clubs like hey you're kind of ugly
or women go hey he's not tall enough we
kind of do it a little yeah especially
sexually
yeah we do can't get on the roller
coaster if you're this short whatever it
is you know we do it in some capacity
but here this would be like
fully transparent
and to a degree that uh it's hard to
imagine like the way we currently do it
you can at least get around it yes you
can at least like trick your way onto
the roller coaster even if you're short
right or the fat guy can get rich so he
can get laid you know there's other ways
at the risk of asking the totally wrong
person this question uh what advice
would you give to young people today
in high school and college about how to
um have a successful career
or career that they're proud of or maybe
have a life that they're proud of ooh
well first of all you got to be
you got to want a life you're proud of
not everybody has any integrity
people just a lot of people just want
short money
i want to feel good
look good right now
i want to do molly boom i'll feel good
you know but you should
space it out you should it's almost like
saving money so you can use it later
nobody wants to save money what do they
say like 11 of america actually has
money saved a thousand dollars or some
[ __ ] it's wildly low
everybody wants it now now
what do you call it immediate
gratification
i think
the key to
happiness and satisfaction is working
for something
even if it's uh it's like a baby if you
could have a baby in five minutes if a
woman you gotta you [ __ ] in her and
she had a baby five minutes boom newborn
healthy
i think he'd be more likely to throw it
away
if you can make it that quick it's the
fact that you spent nine months back
breaking the labor the lactating the
ripped placenta and the hymen or
whatever the [ __ ]
that's what makes you love it and i
think it's the same with comedy or or
making money or whatever look at these
kids who like child stars they all
become heroin addicts at like 22 because
they've just their sensors are burned
out they're pleasure sensors you didn't
have to earn it
i think earning it is a big part of life
and uh always try to do better try to do
more try to learn new things hey i'm
bored i life sucks like play the piano
then you chooch but you you won't do it
because it takes effort and failure and
all that but that's the good part yeah
and i know it's hard to see
so i think that's uh that's a good
good key to life is work hard it's
something you care about and then
love the result
the hard work the journey is actually
way more important than just getting
something everybody wants to go on
amazon i got a package then you feel
good for 10 seconds and
all right let's go on amazon again and
then you're just it's just a dumb cycle
of you being
disgusting and gluttonous
so work for it
everybody wants to take steroids and
just poop i'm buff why'd you point at me
well i'm just rushing or what
i saw the the icarus yeah but no i'm not
saying you're on roids i'm just you'd be
way bigger but uh i'm just saying you
know
work for something and then i would also
young people eat [ __ ] early
eat [ __ ] early i know a guy who kind of
got cancelled or whatever and he had an
out early but he tried to get by and he
tried to ride it
and it all came crumbling down but if he
had eaten it early like yeah i [ __ ] up
i did that
whatever it was
he would have he would have just kind of
been been [ __ ] on for a month and then
it would have gone away but now it's his
whole identity and that sucks so eat
[ __ ] early and i know it's hard to see
what i mean early i'm in the present but
look ahead look back this time will pass
i mean look at high school high school
was the biggest thing in our lives oh my
god this exam susie q hates me the
football player beat me up i'll never
recover now you don't even think about
high school it's just a blip in your
dumb life you know and that's what this
is now this will just be a blip so
remember that
and work towards something and uh
work hard and
care about the result if the result
isn't good try it again and failure is
not always bad failure we look at
failure is this
end-all be-all my life's over i failed
but failure is really just learning
so that's something so in summary
eat [ __ ] early and
eat [ __ ] often yes
all right
mark norman 8 ass
that's the escalated quickly all right i
have a list of random questions for you
um
what activities make you lose track of
time oh
um have that go into that zone you have
this happiness contentment about you
that you just truly enjoy
yeah i think uh good conversation like
i'll sit at the comedy cellar with
friends maybe a little whiskey's flowing
and when you're really just vibing and
inhib inhib in
in a bitty you can do it what is it
inhibited uninhibited
when you're just vibing you're
uninhibited you're saying crazy [ __ ] and
you're laughing and you're not worried
am i seeming cool right now am i seeming
likeable when you're just you 100 and
it's all coming out of you and then
they're saying stuff and you go back and
forth and you feel that excitement oh
they're talking but i want to say my
thing and you know you get all keyed up
i love that and and i look at my watch
i'm like [ __ ] it's three in the morning
this is we've been talking for five
hours so i love that that makes the time
fly by also i bought a speaking of
self-driving cars i bought a 1973 bmw
car
and it's classic and it's stick shift
and it's
grizzly and gritty and rusty and it's a
bucket of bolts but i love driving it
bucket of bulls yeah tom waits they're
poets have you uh have you taken like a
long trip anywhere like road trip in
your life or with this bmw not with it
it's pretty new but i will it's it's a
new 90s yeah yeah it's new to me
and it just it it it goes in the face of
everything we're doing now everything is
digital everything is automated
everything is hands off everything is
delivered and this is the most hands-on
thing in the world and i am dialed in
man i got the tachometer i keep an eye
on that oh i made i put the wrong gear
in [ __ ] oh it's about to stall put some
gas put some clutch and it's all just
brain power and and staying in focus and
all that and it's the opposite of
tweeting and texting and uh watching
porn or whatever so
i almost needed that in my life so i
bought this card just to have this
little exercise
i hope you don't mind that i'm just
trying out random questions i wrote on
you that are completely
they're like completely insane i'm a
guinea pig jizz in my face bring it on
baby
this would be edited down to five
minutes oh if everyone on earth
disappeared
and it was just you left
what would your
days look like what would you do that's
tough because i'm already an introvert
and i try to avoid people mostly like i
like a one-on-one
but uh
crowds and all that is tough
so
basically unchanged yeah that's what i
was gonna say but then that's the irony
is i would be so sad to not talk to
anybody so it's this weird
uh bittersweet thing but
i don't know what i would do man i guess
it's kind of like when you're hungover
you just go into the primal survival
mode i gotta get food i need water i'm
horny jerk off you know you just go
you're not like playing the piano or or
painting or at the gym
so i think i would just go into urges
man primal urges find food store food
am i safe make weapons
build a shelter that i can't get
attacked in i would go all survival mode
and then once i maybe realized if i was
safe or not there's no wild roaming dogs
i would start exploring
and uh you know maybe somehow get a
vehicle and i would try to expand and
that would be it and maybe i'd journal
exploring to what to
to try to find new experiences new new
life if there's other maybe there is
another guy out there oh so always
there's a possibility yeah hope
and then maybe there's a better place i
could live let's find that and then
moving on maybe there's more food over
here so yeah the hope would drive me
but it would be bleak and sad and
horrible also so what you're saying is
you really want other people to be there
so you can hide from them yes yes well
said
all right what uh what's an item on your
bucket list that you haven't done yet
think about something
you'd be very upset if you died and you
haven't done well i'm terrified of
having kids you know just because i'm a
child myself and i'm i'm
selfish and lazy in a way so kids are
like this is your whole life now this is
it you gotta not let this thing die you
gotta love it you gotta raise it
so kids scare the [ __ ] out of me but i
also feel like if i don't have them i'll
i'll i'll regret it
well you've seen so many people
like you who are fundamentally changed
by kids yeah like it's a source
it's it's a source of like a deep source
of happiness even though you didn't
anticipate it yeah
so you like you penciled it into your
bucket yes yes you're it might be on
there okay and you want kids yeah
well i want kids i want to get married
um
i want to have kids i kind of uh
i don't like choice so
in the following way like
i appreciate the value of scarcity and
the power of scarcity like i don't like
the the modern dating culture it's not
some religious thing whatever i just
like
one girl for a long time
uh or at least swinging for that always
like swinging for the fences and to be
swinging right now i mean you're there's
a different use of the word swinging
sure sure but i'm saying you can be
clear you look great you're handsome
yeah thank you muscular thank you you
get the job done so i feel like you
wouldn't leave without an orgasm on her
yeah i just like to you know about
furries i like to dress up as animals
and and i just have trouble finding
others who would like to say out there i
could show you some chat rooms
you're also my coach for the internet
okay
uh
what are you most afraid of
i guess i'll done live life
uh
i'm a i'm i was a big fan growing up of
like
wild guys you know like these teddy
roosevelts who would go out and hunt
lions and
uh
like bar fighting guys i was obsessed
with hunter s thompson types
and look
this is what i love about uh guys like
who's a good example like hemingway
hemingway was the manliest guy he had
the rifle and the elephant gun and the
whiskey and the writing and the women
and the fistfights
but people forget that the other side of
that coin is i'm sure he was in a lot of
hotel rooms weeping i'm sure he was
lonely as [ __ ] i'm sure he had some
wicked hangovers i mean he killed
himself for christ's sake so obviously
he was dealing with something
so the key to me is having this
adventurous life living to the fullest
doing crazy [ __ ] scaring yourself but
also not killing yourself like also not
hating because i used to party a lot
hard i used to
bang a lot of gals and this is the flip
side is like this girl hates you now or
you got herpes or you're hungover or
your mom is like where where are you you
never call me anymore and you're like oh
my mom i
let let ties go with my mom i gotta
connect so this horrible there's a
horrible side of the party animal the
keith richards we don't see
is not pretty
i mean he's already weird-looking but
he's partying he's smoking he's living
but there's another side of that coin
and i think the key to life is
living that [ __ ] crazy awesome badass
life and also
having some
you know meaning and and a little bit of
uh what's the word
not just not killing yourself not going
sad not being depressed right there's a
medium there a sweet spot
does that make sense yeah yeah so taking
big
leaps and uh
hemingway grabbing life by the balls but
at the same time not crushing the balls
then yeah metaphor work it off perfect
like evil knievel we all know him what a
badass fearless oh man what a cool dude
he's got balls of steel but he also
lived like the back half of his life in
a [ __ ] uh you know barca lounger
where his legs were made of steel and he
couldn't see straight and his dick
didn't work so
you know what i mean you got to have a
balance but you still want the balance
i'm willing to take a little bit of [ __ ]
for
a little bit of fun
but you don't want to go too hard
because you got to still risk it i mean
hunter s thompson
it didn't end well
yeah that's quite a ride quite a ride
what small act of kindness were you once
shown that you will never forget
wow that's a great question
you're you're you're i just wrote these
for the guinea pig you're the guinea
that's great that's the keeper okay
that's the keeper yeah this is where
like workshopping questions here all
right i'll take it now you're open
biking yeah this is your version um
let's see there's a couple ladies in
high school who were kind enough to hand
job me that was nice which i really
appreciate i don't think women know how
much that means to us you know when
we're like i'm not a piece of meat or
whatever and you're like i know but if
you just gave me a hand job yeah i would
it would make my world it's like telling
a kid he's smart or loved see most
people mention like a math teacher
middle school that that would inspire
them to get into science you you it's
give a shout out to the well that's part
of that's not the nicest but i'm just
saying that goes a long way all right uh
let's see kindness that's a great
question
uh i want to give you a good answer i uh
i got lost when i was like six i was was
walking around my dad and i zoned out
and went away and
next thing you know i don't know where i
am i'm in a neighborhood this old guy
finds me crying on a lawn somewhere and
he goes uh come inside and he tried to
call my parents and nothing came of it
eventually they found me after like nine
hours cops were there the fbi's out
there [ __ ] helicopters
and i guess you know that's nice this
old guy took me in for a couple hours
and just sat me down and
kept me safe
that's something yeah oh how about enos
my transvestite nanny
very kind
he uh did you hear about this no okay we
had this transvestite nanny he was like
a drag queen but it was in the 90s so it
was weird it was new
and uh my bike got stolen and he
you know my parents were like yeah what
are you gonna do they're poor kids you
know and he was like [ __ ] it let's we're
gonna go get that bike and i was like
this guy's in a wig in high heels big
black guy and i'm like uh
ah what are you gonna do you know it's
gone and he's like no we're gonna go get
it so we got in the van and drove around
my neighborhood saw the kids [ __ ]
with the bike you know five street tuffs
and uh he goes all right
you want to come out or should i just do
this and i was like you do it i'm
terrified what are you crazy
and he
got out of the van in full you know
heels and wig and he went up to these
guys and they went off oh my god look at
this [ __ ] guy homo [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] you know it's the 90s and he just
stared at him
long enough to where they were kind of
like all right well i guess we're gonna
fight you now
and he goes uh that's not your bike
and they go what are you gonna do about
it and he puts his hand on the middle of
the bike and they didn't do anything and
he just picked it up and said that's
what i thought put the bike over
shoulder slid the van door open threw
the bike in and we drove off
somebody stuck up for you yeah and you
know i mean he could have got i mean
they have tools they could have [ __ ]
tuned him up two seconds
that actually like takes courage oh yeah
real courage and then that
the the the reason you do an act like
that is that
makes a kid like you feel like
there's somebody on your side that's
powerful someone on your side is big
it's big that goes a long way
especially when they have uh the risk of
getting their ass kicked or their job
taken away or whatever it is
now we're gonna get uh
philosophical maybe a little bit
emotional
would you rather lose all your old
memories or never be able to make new
ones
it's a tough one but i'd go easy answer
make new ones
but don't you think all the shitty
things that happened to you
oh so my hard drive is wiped clean it's
not
is it memories or is it how every memory
affected me
too
i mean this is a very how do they go
hand in hand i i think
the reality about memories is you replay
them often you go back to them even when
you're not aware of it you really go you
go back often like that um and they
change you change them too yeah you
change them to suit
your understanding of the world yes
and so
uh the the dark view you have
both the hope and the cynicism you have
about the world is so deeply grounded in
the um
in the memories that you're basically i
would say if you erase all memories
i think you're really starting over
with maybe the wisdom of how the world
works
but not
your so much your personality is gone
you would really
um
it'd be interesting how your comedy
would change maybe you would have a good
sense of timing you have a good
sense of like the writing process maybe
but like
now you're making some good points but
let me ask you this let's say i go to
lake cuomo with my girlfriend
now like i wipe the memory or i keep my
old memories let's say i go to you know
the tuscany with the lady yeah
i just won't remember that yeah but you
get to experience it in the moment okay
you'll get to enjoy it can i look at a
photo of it
yes but what the hell is this exactly oh
fascinating it's exactly the rules are
pretty simple yeah i think everyone
knows how the rules go
see but you you would uh yeah so what uh
well i was gonna say start new ones but
then i realized i wouldn't be who i was
without them yeah that's what you're
saying so i guess i'd keep them because
i am 38 so i've
gotten a good chunk out of life yeah and
let's be honest how many years do you
have left i know right i got aids
is it better to have loved okay this
question is ridiculous is it better to
have loved and lost or to have never
loved at all the the it sounds cliche
but yeah there's a question
definitely better to loss
so you enjoy the ups and downs yeah
that's what that's life
for sun and rain baby
i kind of like both the whole thing the
the loss
every time you lose something it really
makes you distinctly realize
how much you valued it yes like am i
when i'm sad
like when i'm feeling alone
and i'm sitting there alone at home
and i wish i could hang out with
somebody
that's like a
realization how awesome people are yeah
so it's like the missing the
yeah uh
we don't have a lot of that in life
anymore because we can have anything we
want immediately so the missing has gone
away which again
drives down the joy of having it
so i i
think you're right you need both
uh so like you said you have a condition
that a terminal condition not much many
years left do you think about your
mortality
all day every day are you afraid
not afraid because it's inevitable so
it's more like
how are we going to handle this
it's like the winner is coming let's
stock up on some [ __ ] nuts but the
existential nature of it like the fact
that this ride ends like what the hell
are you doing any of this for like is it
your satisfaction happiness
short term but like the
there is a presumption there
that it kind of goes on forever i think
if you truly think about the fact that
it ends
um your brain almost shuts shut down
yeah there's some kind of like
protective like uh
switch that just goes off i mean that's
why the stoics
you know encourage people to meditate on
death because it somehow
reorganizes your priorities it helps you
like
holy [ __ ] this ends make the most of the
day yes it's just a nice thing but still
you can't quite comprehend the thing
ends uh little things too you know
people go like oh we got a layover
between our flights it's an hour what
are we gonna do for an hour it's like we
mean what are you gonna do for an hour
you're gonna kill and let's kill how are
we gonna kill this hour
this is part of your life you're just
trying to get rid of it you're trying to
kill it that always blew my mind like
hey [ __ ] it let's go hit the the airport
bar let's get a you know a candy bar or
something yeah anything with bar
but uh it's just
you gotta live i hate this like how are
we going to burn oh the bar didn't open
for 15 minutes what are we gonna do well
we got 15 minutes we got the world is
our oyster yeah make the most of it yeah
and like the like you said in modern day
actually the boredom is a gift like
the when you're waiting for something
that's that's that's a gift
you get to be with your thoughts yeah
those those are the same thoughts you'll
have when you're on your deathbed
there won't be a
uh you won't be scrolling tick tock on
your deathbed i hope not jesus you'd be
a lot more actually maybe you would be
what if that existed because it would be
a good uh like content creators would be
like oh i'm dying this would be good
content
yeah i want to be able to film the exact
moment it goes like last words i wonder
what my last year will be yeah good way
to like end the the account with a bang
yep i like that well you know you ever
seen that meme or the old guy in bed he
goes i wish i had tweeted more you know
and then he dies
it's so true it could be the future uh
what do you think is the meaning of life
i don't think there is one
everybody always throws that out there
there isn't a meaning i think we're here
we're lucky to be here i think there's
no afterlife there's no heaven that's
that's all [ __ ] we tell ourselves to
feel better and i think you gotta just
it's like saying what is the meaning of
this
uh
food i made
well it's just you enjoy the food you
try to get the most out of it you
you built the food you've prepared it
so
just
get what you can out of it
don't die
and try to make it last as long as
possible
yeah but you look at earth it's like
four billion years old
and uh life started early on like like
simple cell bacterial life like a one
billion years in and then it started
like having lots of
uh aggressive interaction eventually
there's predator and prey and then sex
lots of sex lots of sex oh yeah lots of
violence oh yeah uh and then you know
through natural selection there's just a
whole evolutionary process of
of animals that have loved and lost and
murdered and gotten murdered and all
that kind of stuff and it's somehow led
to human civilization and we're super
busy
trying to create things and creating
beautiful art creating beautiful comedy
yeah um just always creating something
new it feels like it's tending down or
something like it's it's a little not
dying
if you die tomorrow you still have all
these hours of pods so it's kind of you
think you're cheating death in a
subconscious way i think
right you know who ernest becker is and
i've heard the name
um it's a book called denial of death
this idea that
that uh if you don't acknowledge
what's on my shelf
uh girls love it like
uh no i'm just
i'm saying you want to bring told story
that's the russian literature it's the
back to norm it's good to bring to uh
because because uh
no american has read any russian
literature but they all appreciate it if
you bring it and it's not like they're
going to ask you any legitimate
questions because they haven't read it
yeah so you can always pretend like
you've read it so it's a little dense
can we get a shortened version
cliff notes yes or make a movie with uh
you know ben stiller that i that i can
just go oh this is based on
what is it uh life and death no what's
the war and peace one piece yeah yeah
yeah so ernest becker's theory and
there's this whole terror management
theory that basically says that like
our terror of death our fear of death is
one of the
central creative forces of the human
condition it's the reason we're trying
to yeah cheat death we're trying to
delude ourselves that somehow we can
become immortal through our art that's
why you've uploaded your special to
youtube because you think
you think you're special will outlive
all of human civilization you think
youtube will outlive all of your
civilization i could go away tomorrow
that can go away tomorrow all of this
can go away so i'm
truly grateful
mr mark norman that you would spend
your uh very valuable time with me today
even though it could all go away this
could be the the last day of our lives
and
won't you be quite upset this is how you
spent it ah yeah you're a hotel room
what am i yeah you're like harvey
weinstein here you heard me up but now i
feel [ __ ]
just wait what we uh
have ready for you after the podcast is
over hi brother thanks so much for
talking today thank you it was great
comedy
thanks for listening to this
conversation with mark normand to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
mark norman himself on his twitter which
you should definitely follow because
it's hilarious
the worst thing about getting omicron
for christmas
is you know it was re-gifted
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time